I know you're a very busy person and
you've been very generous with your time
I really have been and I
um your people made it very clear to me
that this was you know not
high on your list of things to do and
the rate you charged my God thanks for
coming up to the number 150
000 yeah for a 45 minute conversation
that's incredible and that's at a
discount yeah and a private jet and you
drove down the street you just charged
us the amount of a private jet
um but I'm uh I'm and I don't know time
time with you is time very well spent I
adore you and um back at you well back
at you doesn't really count as a
compliment oh god
um well then I'm taking it back
completely smart
uh but keep making the podcast because I
really like it thank you and uh it is I
you've you've done all 10 for this
season is that right yeah tomorrow uh
well yes by the time this yes I've done
all ten okay yes I've done all ten okay
uh wiser than me these are really great
conversations and
um I love that you're out there how
having those conversations I think it's
a very cool project yeah so fun thank
you going and I will one day put on a
wig and some lipstick and I will come in
and you will interview me as an older
woman a wise older woman by the way I
just have to tell you one quick thing do
we
did
your actually I've done your podcast a
couple times because I did it during the
pandemic that's right is that right no
we did it on Zoom we did it on zoom and
the reason I know this is because we
were talking and you were commenting I
wish I'd remember to bring it in today
God damn it but anyway you were
commenting on everything that was you
know my bookshelves and like that
and so I said wouldn't it be funny if I
had a picture of you
was it your TV show TV show but I said
wouldn't it be great if you had a
picture of me and then you sent I sent
you a picture you sent me a picture
framed and I I do have it no of course
no no I've got in a drawer but I'm
saving it for that joke throw a junk
drawer yeah it's in my jungle it's like
with the Scotch tape and extra paper
when people open the door it's there
come on I wish I'd brought it today
but anyway whatever in a drawer
well there goes that's not the trash
look at it that way stay positive
State hey there's another thing we could
all learn stay positive yeah Julia
Louis-Dreyfus yes uh you're uh I love
you thank you for being here I really do
back no don't stay back at you back
to the Future I'm gonna go watch that
movie